this offshore rig pumps oil and gases
off the coast of Nigeria
for more than 60 years petroleum has
been the pillar of its economy
and for many here life without oil is
simply unimaginable we know for sure
that even by 2050 first of all will
still account for about 58 percent of
energy production in the world that
means that fossil fuel is not going to
go away but it's going to be combated to
much much cleaner cleaner Fuel and that
is really our Focus
petroleum contributes more than half of
Nigeria's budget and more than 90
percent of its foreign exchange earnings
experts say ditching it could devastate
the economy
the World Bank says Nigeria's dependence
on oil is greater than that of many
other major producers more than half of
Africa
Africa say they want to increase access
to electricity especially by exploiting
the country's oil and gas resources to
encourage growth
industry experts say Africa's oil will
still find a ready Market on the
continent even if the rest of the world
shuts its doors Africa needs energy
we are not selling energy outside
because we don't need it we are selling
energy outside because we are Miss we
have misplaced priorities
Nigeria wants to be seen as playing its
part in reducing global warming two
years ago the government declared 2020
to 2030 as a decade of gas a 10-year
period to shift focus on oil and more to
natural gas as a cleaner transition fuel
but that doesn't mean the country will
abandon its 37 billion barrels of crude
oil reserves all together Muhammad Idris
Al Jazeera Port Harcourt